avez vous déjà eu l'impression de perdre
complètement le contact avec la réalité
de plus arrivent à distinguer votre
environnement matériel de votre
imaginaire c'est ce qui m'est arrivé l
été passé j'étais plongé dans le coma
artificiel pendant dix jours on était
dimanche 18 juillet j'appelle le 144 je
dois être hospitalisée au chu van raison
d'une détresse respiratoire et d'une
intense douleur dans la poitrine
je suis dans l'ambulance je perd
progressivement conscience
j'arrive aux soins intensifs je vois les
ambulanciers les infirmières qui me
déplace sur une civière puis un scanner
c'est à ce moment que commence mon
voyage intérieur
plus tard j'ai soudain l'impression de
reprendre conscience comme si quelqu'un
avait rallumé la lumière mais je ne suis
plus dans le même endroit
dans un premier temps je crois me
trouvais dans un univers virtuel comme
dans un jeu vidéo ou à l'intérieur d'une
série télé je me promène dans une petite
ville qui pourrait être montreux je
m'entretiens avec une femme une
galeriste ou une antiquaire
puis je suis comme paralysés dans une
cage d'escalier vitré et mon regard se
fixe sur des vitraux peints et un
lampadaire lui-même accrochée à la
façade d'une maison voisine
ça ressemble à un bug car je ne peux
plus bouger pendant ce qui me semble
être une éternité
dans un autre épisode je suis
alternativement un humain moi même donc
et un très grand singe vert
allongée sur le dos et entouré de câbles
et d'appareils je suis couché dans une
structure métallique qui est supporté
par des filets et entouré de building
comme si on était à manhattan
j'entends autour de moi des voix de
femmes qui discutent parfois c'est du
babillage à d'autres moments je ressens
davantage de stress et de tension
en permanence j'entends de la musique
une chaîne radio comme option musique
aux nostalgies il faut préciser à ce
sujet qui avait probablement de la
musique
aussant intensifs dans la salle où je me
trouvais parce que les infirmiers ont
demandé à ma compagne qu'est ce que
j'écoutais comme genre de musique gl a
dit la vérité c'est plutôt du rock
alternatif et du métal ils se sont dit
ça va peut-être être un peu brutal pour
les soins intensifs on va plutôt
lui-même du blues
mes principales préoccupations pendant
cette période sont les suivantes d'une
part communiquer avec ma compagne
pourrait essayer de faire en sorte
qu'elle ne s'inquiète pas trop d'autre
part trouver une solution pour sortir de
ses rêves interminables
comme j'ai l'impression de participer à
un jeu vidéo je me dis qu'il est peut
être connectée à internet
donc à l'intérieur du coma comme ça
j'essaie de développer des stratégies je
dois pouvoir envoyer un email à ma
compagne je pars à la recherche de
l'emballage du jeu dans une ville
futuriste délabré qui ressemble un peu à
l'univers de blade
je fini par retrouver cet emballage sur
la boîte bleue de ce logiciel fabriqués
au canada oui c'est assez précis parfois
il ya des informations en différentes
langues en tout petits caractères mais
rien sur une éventuelle connexion à
internet
à un moment je me vois dans un lit
d'hôpital le dos relever est entourée
d'hommes qui portent des combinaisons
bleues
un de ses personnages m'annonce que ma
compagne va venir me voir
elle entre dans la pièce m'embrasser
reste un moment pour discuter quand elle
repart j'espère qu'elle se souviendra
est revenu me voir à l'intérieur du rêve
quand elle sera de retour dans la
réalité est-ce qu'on me suivait
un endroit très important je séjourne de
manière récurrente est un appartement
ultramoderne situé dans un building
d'une très grande ville japonaise comme
tokyo à proximité dans un passage
souterrain
figure l'inscription suivante
fondation pour le rétablissement de
christophe moreau
l'intérieur de l'appartement est
entièrement blanc petit bien rangée
tresses autre japonais à ma gauche des
parois coulissantes et lumineuse servent
de porte à l'ascenseur à ma droite une
cuisine d'où proviennent des bruits
d'eau qui coule et des conversations
entre une femme et ses enfants je suis
assis sur un fauteuil à proximité d'une
lampe sur pied et d'une penderie
un homme entre dans la pièce il porte un
masque bleu contre le choral un virus il
a l'air aussi japonais que l'appartement
je me dis la communication ne va pas
être facile
heureusement il parle français il
m'explique que je suis le bienvenu chez
lui que je peux rester ici le temps
qu'il faudra mais que je vais beaucoup
ennuyé car je serai souvent seul
un moment après qu'elle soit partie je
me rends compte que j'ai oublié de lui
demandait s'il avait des nouvelles de ma
famille
j'attends son retour pendant des heures
des temps en rassemblement des portes de
l'ascenseur
j'ai parlé de cet appartement avec des
infirmières spécialisées en hypnose et
des psychiatres ils appellent ça le lieu
sûr c'est un nombre c'est un endroit
réels ou imaginaires où on se sent à
l'aise et où on peut se réfugier en cas
d' angoisse ou de grands dangers je
pourrai jamais retourner si je le
voulais si c'était nécessaire
certains épisodes sont plus floues que
d'autres mais dans l'ensemble je
conserve des souvenirs extrêmement
précis presque photographique de cette
période
je suis enfermé pendant dix jours dans
un univers étrange où le temps s'étire à
l'infini
le coma artificiel ne sommes pas au
sommeil
ce n'est pas vraiment un rêve
l'expérience s'apparente plutôt à un
voyage conscient à la frontière entre
l'imaginaire et la perception
le film qui ressemble plus à cette
expérience est probablement inception
la sortie du coma qui dure entre trois
et cinq jours n'est pas moins
perturbante les périodes d'éveil
alternent avec des périodes
d'inconscience et d'hallucinations
c'est un moment très paradoxal car les
rêves ont l'air extrêmement réaliste et
la réalité complètement délirante
peu après le réveil je suis déplacé dans
les couloirs du chv couché sur un lit je
ne vois que des flashes lumineux vert
le violet au plafond
dans la pièce où j'arrive tout à l'air
trop moderne le mobilier les écrans les
machines en regardant par la fenêtre je
trouve aussi que la ville futuriste
chaque fois que je regarde une horloge
les aiguillons bouger tout va trop vite
je pense même qu'on est en 2040 et je me
demande ce que c'est ce qui s'est passé
depuis 2021 je pose même la question
suivante à une infirmière pourriez-vous
expliquer un vieil homme comment on
mesure le temps aujourd'hui
comme j'ai été intubé pendant le coma je
ne peux rien boire alors que j'ai
terriblement soif je me dis qu'on a
épuisé les réserves d'eau et que
l'hôpital fait des économies
une infirmière passe de temps en temps
pour moi sprayé de l'eau dans la bouche
vous avez soif monsieur moore on me
demande-t-elle je lui réponds non je
n'ai pas soit je vais mourir de
déshydratation et c'est vraiment ce que
je crois à ce moment là
je pense qu'elle aussi est payé par
cette fameuse fondation pour le
rétablissement de christophe moreau
je le lui dis après tous ces efforts et
tous les moyens investis par cette
fondation pour me tirer d'affaires ça
serait trop bête de me laisser mourir
maintenant ils m'expliquent patiemment
qu'elle n'est pas payée par mafate
fondation mai par le chef et qu'on est à
lausanne en 2021
le 3 septembre après sept semaines
d'hospitalisation et un certain nombre
de péripéties dont je vous épargne le
détail je rentre à la maison et je
reprend progressivement une vie normale
la rééducation est la médication se
termine en novembre période à laquelle
je recommence aussi à travailler
je n'aime pas trop le terme de
résilience qui fait référence un métal
qui reprend sa forme initiale après
avoir été déformés je n'ai pas retrouvé
ma forme initiale cet épisode a été un
bouleversement violent temps pour ma
famille mes proches que mes collègues de
travail
ils ont dû affronter leurs émotions tout
en s'occupant au mieux des tâches de la
vie quotidienne en mon absence pour la
société aussi évidemment une
hospitalisation de longue durée génère
des coûts financiers et humains
considérables
malgré tout je suis ressorti de cette
aventure avec un nouveau regard sur moi
même les autres et le monde qui nous
entoure
géré évaluer mon sens des priorités et
tente plus que par le passé de réévaluer
de retrouver un équilibre entre le
travail les loisirs la famille
j'essaye aussi parfois de prendre les
choses avec davantage d'humour et de
légèreté monsieur je vais dire mon
infirmière de référence quand même on
rigole bien non elle m'avait répondu
monsieur mort on sait déjà pas rigolo
d'être à l'hôpital on va pas non plus
tirer la gueule
pour avoir expérimenté la durée infinie
du coma ce que je ne souhaite à personne
au passage j'accorde plus d'importance à
l'organisation du temps
les dizaines de personnes qui ont pris
soin de moi et qui m'ont soutenu d'une
manière ou d'une autre monties rendu
plus attentif aux autres à leurs
attentes et à leurs besoins
par contre cette histoire ne m'a pas
rendu beaucoup plus patient je supporte
même moins qu'avant les gens qui partent
dans tous les sens tourner en rond ou se
noie dans un verre d'eau et ceux qui
parlent trop longtemps c'est pourquoi je
vais m'arrêter là en vous remerciant
pour votre attention
[Applaudissements]